my name is Brandon and I'm with a group
called invested interests invested
interest is a
website group of financial advisors kind
of web Savvy Tech kind of guys who are
interested in uh providing social
investing information for a younger
generation
which you know just by looking at
everybody kind of this generation 20 30
40 year old
so kind of
sexing up Social investing a little bit
making a little more interesting and fun
on our website we provide things like
free tools that you won't be able to
find anywhere else to help you make
social investing decisions on your own
um you know kind of news articles kind
of where the current trends and events
are in Social investing I've been doing
this for about eight years
I have you know around 100 clients most
of those are social investors
and uh
when I was younger
you know just graduating School kind of
my personal stories I was torn between I
really enjoyed Finance but at the same
time I wanted to you know kind of do
something good something I could sleep
well at night
and it just through time I've progressed
to social investing I kind of found it
on my own though through General finance
and providing financial services so I
put that out there after the
presentation if any of you are kind of
in that same position right now and
you're wondering you know how do you
know I reconcile these types of uh you
know feelings and you know what I want
to do with life I could speak to that
um and being younger I can kind of
provide a unique perspective on our
generation
you know our perception of social
investing what we demand out of returns
types of social investing products that
are out there
and um and then finally right now
invested interest is providing all the
social investing content for the net
impact website that's something that we
just started doing a couple months ago
so if anybody has seen that and has any
recommendations or would like to talk
about that uh we've begun that
relationship recently and we'll continue
doing that for uh
going forward so I'll let Pierre
introduce himself personally
hey everyone
I'm French my name indicates I've been
in the industry of sustainability
investing for a bit more than 10 years
now
my background is in engineering but I
have a passion for corporate
sustainability
was precise the environmental
sustainability I've been with innovas
for for six years now working both as an
analyst and then studying business
development
I was recently I implemented the
activities of universe in Continental
Europe with offices in Paris
and so I'm very proud to be working with
this forum that has been growing uh
quite rapidly in the last seven years
were a little
north of about 50 professionals more
than 40 analysts web offices in in many
countries headquartered in New York
I hope this is in Toronto London Paris
Madrid Melbourne a partner in Stockholm
Rome and a distributor in Japan so our
coverage is the msci world and we as you
I will talk about we're not really an
SRI
player in that sense who would consider
ourselves as more of a financial
advisory firm with their specialization
in analyzing non-traditional factors of
performance of risk opportunities
quality of management and governance and
with a specialty specialty in analyzing
those sustainability drivers
so with that I'll let the flow to
Brandon
to introduce the uh the space in the U.S
yeah
um so I think I'm ready to
start a slide presentation I know we
were told not to have too many
PowerPoint slides
um so of course Pierre and I put quite a
few PowerPoint sides together but just
the PowerPoint slide is going to be kind
of a
additional information on what I'm
talking about I'm not just going to read
off of it but if if I do not talk about
something you guys have a question just
jot it down we get the question answer
you guys can ask me about something
um
and
uh just kind of give you an overview
before I get started I'll just I know
you didn't come here for kind of a
history lesson but I'm not sure where
everybody's experience with social
investing is that so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to like quick nutshell
like two minutes uh just kind of bring
up the speed a couple events in the
history of the United States and history
of the world and financial uh matters
kind of how we've gotten where we are
right now in Social investing then we're
all kind of on the same page
um and then from there
talk about
um
kind of the predominant uh
social issues the way that American
investors look at Social investing today
is what I see is like the trends across
all the products and services there's
something called the three pillars of
social investing that we can talk about
and then from there really getting into
like specific products you know like the
how to's that's what I do I'm kind of
the nuts and bolts financial advisor
um and uh and then from there hopefully
you guys will jot some things down about
some questions so I'll begin
um and so
of course the idea was to talk about
where how we got to where we are in the
United States in Social investing so I
decided to pick somebody who isn't in
the United States or never was
um John Wesley was one of the founders
of the Methodist Church so
the reason I'm pulling this up
this is a long time ago in in a matter
of fact I mean throughout all of history
there's been mentioned of money in uh
you know by religious leaders by
different religions but John Wesley was
really one of the first people to write
he wrote a sermon called the use of
money about the ills of
poor Investments about how Investments
can harm I think you refer to like
streams and rivers around us
um and uh
it it definitely was one of the first
instances where somebody made a
methodical him being a Methodist
approach and documentation of social
investing and and that the ills of uh
like I said poor investing
um
and
he was alive in the 1700s so you can
kind of see this is starts a long time
ago
um and uh
from John Wesley I'm going to jump a few
hundred years to the Vietnam War and the
reason I point this out I really see the
Vietnam war in the history of the United
States is the beginning of kind of
modern social investing
um so investing around
an issue around a company
and a product that they sell so Dow
Chemical created two products that are
fairly notorious Napalm and agent orange
during the Vietnam war
um one of the interesting things is the
first reaction of Dow Chemical when
people were protesting and actually
students at Berkeley students around the
country when Dao chemical recruiters
were coming to their schools actually
protested against the recruiter so
there's this real direct connection
between Dow and this product that hadn't
really been made before with other
products in the history
and I don't know if you guys can see I
mean everybody it's a horrible picture I
put it there for just to remind us I
mean this is this is the product and
this is really one of the pictures and
images that that seared into the
American public's mind you know an
American company made this product that
did this
um I think there's a real kind of
watershed in the history of social
investing that there is a direct
connection between
a product and a company's culpability
and Dow Chemical initially said it was
the pentagon's fault because they use
the product they just made it for the
Pentagon but I think history would show
that the American public really didn't
buy that and a protest against Dao
during the Vietnam war kind of bore that
out
uh and from the Vietnam War moving to
the end of the 70s
the issue of apartheid kind of became
front uh primary issue in Social
investing there's a gentleman by the
name of Leon Sullivan who at the time
was a board member at General Motors and
the issue of apartheid and even people
who are like casually familiar with
social investing was one of the first
times in international history Financial
history that a single issue prompted
different players throughout the world
throughout the capital markets to focus
on a specific issue and bring their
financial leverage and pressure to Bear
against that issue so colleges Pension
funds
you know individual investors were all
involved in divesting or removing their
investments from companies that were
involved in in business in South Africa
and
so that's the history that I want to
bring you up to speed and it my feeling
looking back at the history you know and
also I'm taking a lot of Liberty and uh
in using a lot of information
not necessarily in a direct sense but
that other people who are writing about
social invest in the United States today
kind of the the map and the progression
that they have also seen but for me
personally I see this kind of leading to
and this is a trend I see in Social
investing today that's real tied to
ownership and I think it's going to be
real interesting when Pierre talks
because uh I think Pierre will will talk
about the use of
social investing in kind of a capital
Market sense
where I see in the United States there's
a there's a lot of focus on ownership
and not in my backyard not in my
portfolio type mentality with social
investing and that in many ways that's
the predominant strategy and
understanding of what a social
investment is and this runs the you know
the gamut from you know religiously
screened Investments all the way to you
know real green and liberal type
Investments it's it's a I don't want to
own it I don't want to be a part of it
type of mentality
um and also I you know through history
social investing has really become kind
of a at least in the United States is a
real activist approach
to social investing and
today the most cited kind of structure
for social investing is called the three
pillars of Sri
and when I see the three pillars and
hear mention of this it
it's meant to be a framework to provide
General social change through investment
they're different types of strategies
but the goal is kind of like a
uh you know for life better and
activists you know we're trying to
change the world and here's like a
three-pronged approach to do that
um and just kind of give you a brief
rundown this will come up when we're
talking about the products that are
available today you have the strategy to
divest or to remove your investment from
companies that are violating social
preferences that you may have and this
is called screening or negative
screening so for instance if
if if you do not want to be involved in
companies that were harming the
environment perhaps a negative screen
would remove oil companies remove Timber
companies from your portfolio
the second pillar that's often described
and talked about is the shareholder
resolutions I think there's another
panel discussion at the at this
conference about shareholder resolutions
this would involve actually buying stock
or owning part of the company that you
want to change so you would actively
find a company that is violating a
social issue or doing something that you
on a personal value level don't agree
with
and by owning that company you're able
to
propose shareholder resolutions that are
then voted up or down at shareholder
meetings so you're able to perhaps
change the company from within by owning
a part of the company and uh the third
and I'm not going to really get into
this all that much in this presentation
it's uh it's it's a it's very involved
topic but Community investing uh
Investments that are
directly benefiting a like a
underdeveloped or underserved community
so for instance like a financial
institution that makes underrate loans
to individuals small businesses that
otherwise wouldn't be able to get loans
or they work in communities that are
being overlooked by traditional Banks or
financial institutions so together these
three
pillars of Sri today really drive all
the products and services that are
available to a social investor
um
and like I said I really do see this
kind of coming from an understanding of
ownership being the primary uh
the primary purpose and role of social
investing and kind of like like I said
an activist strategy so this is really
like a three-prong approach
um here's something and I think Pierre
also has this in his so if you don't get
it it'll be coming back around uh SRI
trains the United States as of uh this
is as of 2003 and provided by the social
investment Forum which is one of the uh
online resources that anybody can use
for social investing
um and as you can see for the three
types of social Investments uh you know
of the three pillars that we were
talking about you know how much money is
actually going into these types of
Investments today
or today as of 2003 in the United States
and
get into some of the Investments that
are available today
um
and you know as you guys hear things and
and I have questions just jot them down
this is probably the the part that will
expand upon when the question and answer
stuff comes around but I'm just going to
kind of I'm going to go through it
quickly now but um
this is definitely the the part of the
presentation that that we can talk more
about
and just a a fact as a in 2003 over 2.16
trillion dollars the United States was
invested in uh socially screened
Investments
um and uh that includes Pension funds
endowments and individual Investments
and uh since 1997 uh SRI or screen funds
has grown 240 and actually social
investing is the fastest growing segment
of the financial services industry
um and so as far as you know hitching
yourself to something that's growing
social investing definitely is growing
and I think some of the things that Pier
is going to talk about is probably the
reason why it's growing the fastest is
is when it's proven that social
investing can increase returns or lower
volatility I think you really have
Capital markets behind you you have
large Pension funds endowments jumping
on board um
uh some of the the products that are
available today
you have social mutual funds so for the
Casual investor this is you know the
standard mutual fund uh the additional
service that's being provided is that
screens are being applied to different
types of mutual funds or asset classes
so you have in the world of social
mutual funds there's over a hundred
today available uh you have you know
large domestic you have international
small cap Bond blend balance funds
everything that you would want as an
investor and
you'll have different types of screens
and you should be like a mix of screens
you'll have like three four five
different objectives of the fund so
environment board diversity child labor
tobacco these are some of the screens
that'll come up
the only thing when investing in a
social mutual fund is a lot of times an
investor will be making a maybe a small
compromise as far as
the types of issues they're concerned
with
the way that those issues are being
addressed and so going back to like the
three pillars or the three strategies in
Social investing today so some mutual
funds will actively invest in tobacco
companies in an attempt to change those
tobacco companies some will screen out
tobacco companies so there's different
ways that these mutual funds are
addressing these issues and you know one
thing that we can talk about there's
been articles even within the past year
about
the way and for instance I think it was
the Sierra funds uh the way that they
were addressing environmental issues
within their funds
came an issue
and uh like I said it's something that
we can talk about it's it's really kind
of a it's something where
when I'm advising people it's a you must
have you must read the perspectives you
must know what you're kind of getting
into they usually spell out exactly the
way that they're going to address these
social issues but um it is something
that creates a lot of Confusion And I
think unnecessarily in Social investing
today but it it does remain
another option that
uh that you would uh actually just
talking a little bit more about mutual
funds I mean one of the reasons people
get into mutual fund is because you're
hiring a professional manager to invest
your money and with social funds uh it's
nice because you're also hiring somebody
to apply these social screens the social
data today is very expensive and time
consuming to find Pierre just mentioned
it as that 40 some analysts at innovest
there's only a handful of companies that
do comprehensive social screening
information on publicly held companies
United States and to get this data is
very expensive so for the individual
investor
the time it would take the actual money
it would cost to find these screens very
expensive uh in a cheap and efficient
way to you know get the results of of
all the work that these uh that these
groups are doing would be to invest in a
mutual fund that has purchased that
social information uh
by obviously by buying mutual funds also
you're you know you're hiring a manager
to go out and
grow your money competitively it's
something that's kind of off your table
as an investor also but with mutual
funds you have higher fees some social
funds have higher than normal fees some
of them justify those higher fees
because they're buying social
information or their the the added
effort of
screening Investments on your behalf but
some are competitively priced and that's
something that every investor should
look at
another
way to
oh
you know I just skipped through a couple
but we'll all catch up here in a minute
um another way to get involved in Social
investing is to talk to a social
investment advisor so somebody who
specializes in Social investing and uh
once again the benefit of that would be
and a lot of times social advisors will
purchase this social information so they
could recommend if you came to them and
said you know I'm interested in buying
Microsoft I'm interested in buying X and
Y Z company they would have the
information that you would need as an
investor to say yeah that is or is not a
company that's passing social screens
that you're interested in
and in addition obviously working with
an investment advisor you have the
benefit of somebody
helping you build portfolios helping you
plan for uh you know retirement College
savings all those types of issues that
come up and you know advisors have their
own fees some charge hourly rate some
charge yearly assets under management
some receive commissions for the
products that they put you in
and the third way and I think I kind of
touched upon this when I was talking
about mutual funds would be to invest in
individual Securities on your own so
come
building a portfolio of companies you
know 20 30 different stocks
and then screening them yourselves and
kind of getting back to what I was
talking about mutual funds the
information and the amount of research
that you would have to do it really
makes buying individual companies and
screening them and then staying up to
date because things change uh a lot of
companies that are failing or passing
certain social issues
it may not be next month next year it's
a lot of effort for somebody to do on
their own can be done
um
but it's definitely a cost of doing this
on your own in addition you know just a
straight Financial sense investing in
your own individual companies if this
was your retirement account having you
know two different stocks that you own
you know even though they are
stocks that meet the values that you
have and social preference that you have
isn't probably a financially smart thing
to do unless you're a sophisticated
investor
and
see here are a couple sources of social
information uh you guys may want to jot
down or I think I'm gonna we're gonna
publish these slides and the
presentation online so you can always go
back and I put links in on every page
that I could
um
for information on on social mutual
funds on our site invested interest and
the social investment form we have the
full list of every mutual fund that's
available you can search by different
screening types you can search by
performance or asset class so it's
really it's a good tool for the
individual investor who wants to go the
route of mutual funds and kind of do it
there on their own but definitely you
know not completely on their own they
still want to use a mutual fund
Calvert citizens domini now these aren't
the only three companies that have
mutual funds but they're definitely
three of the largest and uh most
recognized and I didn't feel
at all we're putting their name up at
their reputable organizations
shareholder resolutions a couple
organizations that you can contact to
get involved and like I said the
community Investments is definitely a
topic under unto its own but a good
place to start would be the
communityinvest.org which you can also
find through if you guys are familiar
with the co-op America website and the
co-op America group you can find it
through their website it's actually part
of their firm
and um just kind of getting back and
actually I I these notes I wrote
um
just two days ago I was listening to uh
Lloyd Kurtz is uh is somebody that
um that I've talked to and who is
probably one of the uh he's probably the
walking Encyclopedia of all social
research
on the world uh and uh he was talking on
NPR about this conference and had
mentioned that he feels today uh
cumulative social research has shown
definitely a correlation between
profits and social business practices
but I think the causation
is still up in the air and maybe either
needs to be proven or
is uh is something that's still being
worked on I just want to put that up
there I mean something that we can
always we can talk about
and there's definitely a lot of research
out there a lot of data points if if
somebody's statistically inclined to go
and dig into all that research
and uh that's about that's about it one
last thing also when it when you do get
into screens and I'm glossing over quite
a bit but if if people in the audience
were to go out today and actually look
for Investments of their own you know
like one of the things I'm talking about
with the mutual funds reading the
prospectus one of the things you're
going to come across is like I said how
they're being applied how the social
screens and the social issues are being
addressed one of the things early on
when I'm talking to um to clients or to
prospective clients we fill out an
extensive questionnaire
one of the considerations that you have
to have is like let's say you do not
want to invest in the defense industry
you know one of the first things that
always come up is a company like
Coca-Cola
what do we do about Coca-Cola sells a
lot of coke to the United States
military a lot is does that mean for you
as an individual investor that that's
violating a defense Contracting screen
is that are they part of the defense
Contracting industry and so there's a
lot of Shades of Gray whenever we talk
about any of these issues you know I
have full faith in the organizations
that provide the data I think the
analysts do a great job however
there's still that personal preference
of every investor
um and uh
one thing I noticed it with my clients
the clients that are more flexible have
fewer
values that they want to have screen in
their Investments are more successful
with their investment overall I think
one a strategy that's that I've seen be
very successful is is kind of a greening
of your Investments but not necessarily
an all-out perfect pure investment
and so just want to leave you with that
I think that's something that we can
always that we can talk about it's it's
kind of the nuts and bolts of actually
getting your hands dirty in this uh that
uh
that I can talk about with you guys so
with that done
hand it over to Pier
thank you Brandon for giving a panorama
of
what's been traditionally accepted as
being
the the modes the ways of investing
money in an SRI fashion socially
responsible
before I go into describing the various
um
styles of Sri I'd like to ask you a
question the title of the session is
about where should I invest my money so
two scenarios either it's your own
personal fortune that you want to manage
in which case because you will want to
look for the best returns and if you are
very deep inside moral values that are
really dear to your heart that you like
avoiding a new portfolio so that you
sleep better at night than fair enough I
mean if you have something against
alcohol or tobacco contraception animal
testing nukes whatever I mean you may
have a whole range of values and that's
that's what has been traditionally
accepted in the US as negative screening
investing uh now if you are going to
that space and you are asking yourself
okay we know the demographic of the
planet we know about the plundering of
Natural Resources we know about abuse of
human rights in Emerging Markets we know
about the uh the side effects of
globalization
um we know that um environmental
liabilities we know about um a whole
range of issues and then most of you
guys as MBA student at Stanford and
other leading Business Schools where
you'll have a managerial position in
Industry chances are your money will be
investing your savings will be investing
your pension fund chances are you will
be professional money managers managing
the money of your Pension funds and then
you wouldn't want to make sure that that
the world is evolving in a direction
that is sustainable so the whole concept
of sustainable development of the
coefficiency of corporate social
responsibility at the end of the day
financial in Investments are very
powerful lever to affect changes and at
the end of the day what is perhaps the
most needed out here is being able to
leverage your money
to exert you know to apply Financial
democracy and affecting changes on
corporate Behavior so that at the end of
the day not only in the next five to ten
years but in 50 years 200 years your
children grandchildren will still be
living in a planet that have been nice
to live in
okay so I'd like to approach a pound the
various styles of
incorporating those values and what has
been the the evolution of uh SRI in the
last 40 plus years starting at the left
corner
oops
we have what is traditionally held as
socially responsible investing which is
still the bulk of investing in the in
the US in Sri clearly that's a niche the
figures we talk about are 10 percent
10 percent of assent under management if
we say that in the US there are about 20
trillion dollars worth of assembly
management invested in in large cap
equities and even mid cap and small cap
but inequity investing
SRI as we know of it in the US as as
it's frequently referred to is only 10
of it and and if you look at the pie
most of it is in negative screening and
Counting into that would be all the fans
that have at least
one single criteria Criterion of uh
negative screening could be no tobacco
and that's it that would qualify now the
those funds in the U.S embracing
embracing the full scope of
sustainability involving including
governance issues environmental issues
uh social responsibility social issues
human rights
I mean the slice of that time would be
perhaps less than one percent okay so if
you invest if you I mean that's quite a
good thing that you would want to invest
with your values and say well absolutely
a born nuclear industry I think it's a
something that has no place in a
sustainable future and then you you make
sure that you you find a an advisor will
Implement your strategies and screen out
those stocks now if you want to affect
Corporate social responsibility at large
um
what you may want to do is to consider
that the world is made of a whole range
of Industries at the end of the day
will move towards sustainability it's
kind of a lofty goals chances are we
won't move to sustainability in Quantum
leaps and sustainability is not even an
absolute terms because the factors are
evolving
continuously and what was sustainable
maybe 100 years ago may not be today
because of the very the sheer volume of
consumers India China will want to
access to energy 112 on a car and then
if you apply the same ratio that we have
for example in the US you'll find that
we'll need five to ten planets in order
to sustain us okay so
what are the options uh considering
those parameters if you want to affect
the remaining 90 to 99 percent of those
funds of the mainstream uh towards
engaging with the company so that those
companies will unleash the market forces
you know the uh This brilliant economy
Saddam Smith who had this the proverbial
green invisible hand the Invisible Hand
now what he omitating his stasis is the
fact that there are many externalities
that are not factored in so what we
believe is needed
is to find a way to enlist those Market
forces to situate that those
corporations start competing not only
for capital for customers but also start
competing for having the best social
responsibility and that's something
we've we've seen happening and it's uh
it's increasing so you and you are those
companies are vying to have a AAA within
averse or to be part of their
sustainability index
to uh to really show that they are they
are managing the stakeholders better
that they are reducing the ecological
footprint that they have that they are
better taking care of the employees that
they are innovating for the future and a
whole range of issues that I will
discuss so if you look at this curve
here we still have the bulk of it
especially in the US but not in Europe
anymore focused on negative screening
then in the 80s you had a very
interesting phase focusing on
environmental technology
and those those funds they had a pretty
high volatility I'm not talking about
I'm not talking about Venture Capital
I'm talking here about investing in
waste management companies water
companies
uh what are utilities renewable energies
um maybe small cap those phones had a
were very um
subject to the level of environmental
regulations in various countries and
obviously environmental regulations
fluctuate based on the the political
climate so that was a non-diversified
investment that was not conducive for
massive investment from large pension
fund and other institutional investors
then you had 1992 the famous Rio Summit
and uh
the large multinational at that time
they were really young as critini and
they were they were seen as the prime
culpit and actually
um the cooked world industry is is the
prime contributor to environmental
impact and certain level of social wars
and so the environmental impact needed a
response from large business and they
organized themselves through various
umbrella organization to provide a
response at Rio at real Summit and then
they they call the concept Ray
coefficiency the idea behind that is
that corporate corporations like growth
they like development they like to
increase the numbers
so with the concept of the
coefficiencies it's not only about you
know reducing the size of activity
because obviously if they grow in size
they will consume more energy and they
will produce more waste the ID is is
building ratios metrics of performance a
coefficiency is about producing more
goods and services
with less of an environmental impact
okay so um
traditionally what what uh
Financial Theory tells us is that in
order to reduce the risk we should
diversify our assets okay so if you take
an index
and if you start telling yourself that
well I don't believe the oil industry is
sustainable because it emits CO2 and
thereby you know I don't want to invest
in that well the the uh the sector
contribution to the market cap of the
index I think is above 10 percent it's
very heavy because those companies are
large so if you start excluding those
sectors entirely chances are your
returns will be heard badly because you
will be taking too much of a risk
compared to the index which is your
benchmark for which a money manager is
um you know it's uh
held accountable to uh to stay close to
it because if you take too much of a
tracking area in an investment chances
you're taking too much of a risk
basically
especially lately the oil industry has
been perfect performing pretty well
because of the high prices and the lack
of supply
and security problems so what I'm saying
is that rather than perhaps excluding
entirely a sector that would be
interesting to consider that perhaps the
oil industry and those large old
companies they will be the one having a
lot of
uh Capital to be able to invest in those
new emerging energy technology that will
affect change going forward so I don't
see uh anywhere in the future those
large oil and gas company who are now
really able themselves as energy
companies to really follow their
business say well you know we no longer
produce oil the market doesn't want it
so we're out of business no they will
invest towards the new emerging
Technologies and they will shift their
business model still being energy
providers but perhaps that won't be
based on oil
so really if you want to effect change
because you're aware of climate change
what you may want to do is look at the
coefficiency of the old sector and the
other
60 plus sectors that you have in various
indices and to say well I want to invest
in those
best of the sector
so that you will affect change and by if
you come and you are larger pension fan
you're a money manager investing money
for Calpers or casters and you say well
I have a fan here it's a 120 million
dollars and I'm an analyst I'm talking
to you I'd like I'd like to see where
you stand in terms of
emissions of CO2 in terms of your
investment in renewable energy in terms
of that reducing your risk managing
your human resources and so on so forth
then you start engaging those
Capital to affect changes and companies
start responding and can tell you they
pick up the phone whereas we say well we
uh we're advisors to so and so such and
such money manager and start um asking
them for their CO2 emissions for their
energy use and and deep factors allowing
us to do analysis so that's investing in
a coefficiency that allows to say we're
not about excluding anything
we're about picking the best in the
sector and trying to match that with a
portfolio so that we know that that we
are picking the stocks that have the
least
ecological footprint the less risks that
are better managed that have a better
equivalent governance and our better
capturings what we call Strategic profit
opportunities
then later we had their the social
element of sustainability coming back to
the fore in the field of corporate
social responsibility
that's the the social element including
in the triple bottom line investing
so the idea was that sustainability is
based on three pillars
um economy economic
environmental and social factors
so that led to approaches monitoring
three looking at a company from three
different angles environmental social
and economical Financial
so that led to certain indices that are
still invoked that are very interesting
it's about Crossing various elements
but finally where we are today starting
in the uh
early 2000s
you have the concept that that we
develop being
trying to integrate diverse factors to
look for materiality if we want to be in
a position to affect change across the
99 of our Senator management who are not
paying attention to sustainability
factors we need to demonstrate that
those factors that were relevant to the
share price
all those financial analysts most of
them have no clue as to how to analyze
those companies
they it's simply known they read a
screen to be asking for
for the the race production every year
the energy use their
emissions of CO2 and other greenhouse
gases
it's not there so they are more focused
on the short term whereas sustainability
we look typically at factors that would
be important for generations to come
when we started in 97 analyzing
companies and database way before the
pure protocol entered into Force
and it was ratified this year early in
February
okay we knew that those climate change
factors will have structural impacts in
companies and impacts on competitivity
so of course we're a Pioneers in in
raising the flag and telling our clients
why you should start looking at these
issues because there will be drivers of
future performance so the idea is that
if you want alcohol's presentation
that's what they do at generation
of course told us that it was kind of
more or less the inventor of that
inventing the internet as we say but he
made a really great speech I mean his
his end goal and looking at those
factors of the uh you know the uh the
light spectrum whereby when you look at
her the uh the visual bandwidth is very
narrow and there's a lot of things out
there that's what we capture but in a
somewhat of a different way
we look at a company when we look at a
balance sheet we look at what we call
the iceberg Iceberg balance sheet
okay if you uh look at your if you take
the entire
market capitalization of say the s p
500.
you will find that the financial capital
or the asset value is only no more than
30 percent of the entire market cap and
the rest is made of what it's made of
intangible value factors
okay so there's the willingness or the
the belief that the stock will perform
okay so there's a factor that is based
on a lot of qualitative issues a lot of
believe in management believe in
intangible like intellectual capital
capacity of management uh Wall Street
analyst will tell you that the number
one determinant of stock price is
quality of management
okay governance factors a whole range of
issues that sort of make up the mind of
an analysis and say well you know I
think that company will meet its
expectations
okay so that's
the intangible value you can monitor it
um there's some experts we've done some
research you can really uh for each
stock compute what is the amount of
Goodwill or or intangible value
now the immersed part of the iceberg as
you as you know actually it's more 90
but here that case 70 when we analyze
those non-traditional factors of
performance link to sustainability we
look at factors of sustainable
governance environmental factors or the
equal value the human capital and its
stakeholder capital
so sustainable governance you're also
you're all very familiar with uh you
know all those scandals that happen and
run Worldcom and all those companies
permanent
where a lot of fruits frauds occurred so
these are failure in corporate
governance so that's the traditional
aspects of corporate governance and as a
bunch of regulations that are in place
now uh for firms to have supervisory
committees supervisory boards for for
disassociating the functions of
CEO and chairman and a whole range of
remuneration policies and and
bodiversity and so on and so forth so in
addition to that well that's what we
call Tradition traditional governance
practices in addition to that we look at
the governance of the companies uh
relative to Major sustainability issues
has a typical take the old industry
uh you have on one side John Brown at BP
who's been a serious proponent of
embracing global warming and even uh you
know
renaming his company VP Beyond petroleum
and all these campaigns and that has led
to many many uh programs in place so it
means that the very top management has
in its very DNA factored in the fact the
fact that hey climate change is there
you know the ice caps aren't melting
there's an amount of risk
um there's a European emission trading
scheming place
ton of carbon as a spot price now
trading over 25 Euro which is close to
30 dollars a ton
we know that these things are important
for our strategy let's not hide it
at the end of the other end of a
spectrum you've got CEO of ExxonMobil
Lee Raymond who's been in denial for
many many years okay so that tells you a
lot about the corporate makeup the whole
the subconscious of the of the of the
board
so these are the factors we measure the
Strategic capability of addressing
sustainability issues at Large
then the equal value
um we're measuring the environmental
performance by looking at three
dimensions first we look at the
the environmental risk
then we look at the Environmental
Management
and the capacity of the firm to manage
those risks and then we look at the
upside we look at what we call Strategic
profit opportunities which are ways of
measuring the Innovation capacity of a
firm
what they do to develop new line of
activities that are really positioned to
capture those sustainability drivers
that are mounting and and capturing and
getting a Leading Edge in in being the
first to innovate Casey's point an
illustration I would say Toyota
a lot of firms have been talking about
the hybrid powertrain for a long time
but uh Toyota and Honda were the first
to put it to the market okay so at the
beginning of everybody in the industry
said I don't believe it you know those
cars they cost a million dollars to
manufacture that was a huge amount of
money in what Mass well guess what now
they are sending hundred thousands
especially with the oil price right now
but it's supposed to continue and all
the other firms 10 years later not even
eight years later
they are trying to do the same thing but
they realize that hey it's not that
simple uh you know Toyota Prius inside
of that the technology is very Advanced
Ford told us about five years ago that
they were about to release the Escape
you know only came out this year and
then they they had to license the
technology for Toyota to be able to do
it so that tells you a lot about the
Innovation capacity and so Toyota
understood that in the same way that
they enlarged their market share by
focusing on quality in the 80s and
that's how they really managed to grow
their market share because their cars
are sitting at a premium premium for
Quality they understand that the new
driver for the next 15-20 years and
perhaps more is the environment and they
were earlier capturing that so to
analysis that's what we're trying to
capture
by looking at strategic profit
opportunities
then we look at the human capital
all that has to do with the way the
quality of life of employees and those
who are on board so we look at things
such as Recruitment and Retention
strategies employee motivation
Labor Relations do the employees have
the right to assemble
Innovation capacity how the company
managed to translate
its own vision and Mission to align it
with with employees motivation
knowledge development dissemination
health and safety health and safety
affect really the morale of employees
big time when employees work in a
factory where there's a very high rate
of accidents obviously that you know
that kind of scan that really it's not
really motivating environment
and Progressive work workplace practices
so all those factors are fairly
qualitative with with some quantitative
analysis whenever we can but I would say
that it's less conducive to quantitative
analysis than the environment where we
can really monitor hot data do precise
benchmarking on a coefficiency factors
then we look at the uh the fourth pillar
Force driver of intangible value
stakeholder capital
now stakeholder capital
it's about how the firms relate to
the outside world including Regulators
it's consumers its suppliers
the communities where it operates
um
and spatial issues in Emerging Market
where typically the standards of
corporate performance or not as high as
they are in developing in developed
countries so they are more abuses of
Human Rights and those factors have a
very high potential for hurting
their the brand value or brand brand
capital of the firm
um so in that
typically an issue that will analyze
under that section
is how the firms react and behave in the
case of a an accident or a mishap give
you an example 97
in the art industry you had shell they
had her um
a platform in the North Sea West of the
coast of Norway that reached the end of
life it was a brain's bar it's a it's an
oil stalling platform because we're at
the end of the life they say well you
know I want to maximize profit for my
shoulders what's the cheapest way to to
end that that life cycle and they
decided to sync it to the bottom of the
nose scene
and guess what Greenpeace came around
say well campaign the Earth is not a is
not a garbage I can so you can't you
can't really sink it there and they
started to to do a heavy campaign what
you've seen overnight in Germany German
consumers started to boycott Shell gas
stations overnight shell last
eighty percent of its market share
no 30 sorry they lost 30 market chain
took them 18 months to recover it so at
the end shell had to tour back the
platform and dismantle it cost them
Fortune to do that and uh what we
learned later was quite funny is that
actually Greenpeace that didn't do their
sampling to the right pipeline
you know there's a lot of pipe and they
did some testing and said well look you
know look at these emissions coming up
but it turned out they
they analyzed the wrong pipeline that
was a fitting where there was some
troopings going on and but it doesn't
matter at the end of the day that's the
power of Civilian society as the power
of ngos over large corporations so if
you are as a manager
you manage your firm and you're in firm
denial chances are
the stock price would reflect that very
quickly drop and then it will weaken the
position of the firm an example per year
French company in the food industry
and they had a contamination
through Benzene of their of their Waters
and they were they were not equipped to
manage the accident it was in the 80s
and then so it was a big Scandal food
contamination and they went it was a
real panic and it took a long time to to
remedy to the situation and the stock
price
dropped so fast dwindled to the point
that they were weakened and they were
bullied by Nestle
and there are many examples like this
where companies don't recover after an
accident
so these are the stakeholder Capital
factors
okay so key drivers to
you know to integrating or to factoring
their sustainability issues into share
price development why those
sustainability issues are are poised to
to stay and remain and and intensify
their repercussions on a corporate
performance well there's I mean if you
look at the economics of the world you
look at the developmental Trend you can
see that the environmental impact is
accelerating and and Regulators are
trying to find the right Solutions at
least in Europe and Japan in other parts
of the world to address many of those
factors I'm talking about climate change
so when you see those tougher
requirements obviously the companies
have to innovate they have to uh to be
earlier at finding Solutions so that
they can really operate under a more
constraint world and be more responsible
and reduce their risks
but also in the financial industry what
we've seen in Europe is
is a sort of an institutionalization of
this concept of social responsibility
and now it's sort of a given that social
responsibility include those factors of
governance social responsibility and and
reducing environmental risk and impact
so more and more you've seen in the last
five years we've seen an increasing
number of rfps request for proposal when
pension fund money wants to be invested
housing element of the RFP the fact that
they want their money to be managed with
some sustainability principle
and it's it has
it's happening also in the US we've seen
a recent Trend in rfps in the US from
Calpers and calstrs requesting bidas
money managers to
to integrate principle of environmental
responsibility
okay so we we even have regulations in
Europe where
Pension funds need to disclose the
principle they've adopted as their
guidelines for managing their money
so in in truth what we see emerging is
that
we we have a shift from
the niche market of Sri negative
screening which is you know respectable
if you have principle you should you
should ask your money managers to apply
them but if your money is managed to a
large pension fund you know I encourage
you to to go and ask you uh
ask the money manager if they have any
products including factors of
sustainability because what you want to
do is to have your money that is managed
in such a way that will it will steer
the economy towards a sustainable path
so you want money to work for you both
from a financial return but also from a
environmental and social dividend if you
will sustainability dividend
okay so now what is at stake is no
longer so much the ethical or
values-based principles but it's also
the fiduciary the very fiduciary
responsibility of Trustees because when
you have issues such as climate change
which are demonstrated to be able to
impact the share price they show the
value of a firm not looking to those
factors is not fulfilling the
responsibility the fiduciary
responsibility and that's we've seen a
number of coalitions in the US and
across the world
that that are trying to raise the um the
question and put pressure onto Pension
funds and and fiduciaries to really
start looking into those issues one uh
very um
powerful initiative in that space that
took place over the last four years
that's the CDP the carbon disclosure
project I don't know if you're familiar
with that it's a coalition today the the
third report has been released the idea
is to enlist institutional investors
behind uh the uh the risk and the cause
of climate change to interact with the
fortune family firms and so you have a
coalition of representing 20 trillion
dollars worth of assets and collectively
uh they've sent a letter to the CEO of
each of the fortune family companies
saying we are investors in your firm
collectively represent 20 trillion
dollars of assets and so uh as investors
would like to know if you consider
climate change as a risk as a Financial
Risk to your firm and if so to what
extent what are you doing to curb it
what is your current level of direct
greenhouse gases emission indirect green
eyes gases emissions what is the market
risk to your firm how could it impact
the share price
so that's that's kind of a very powerful
way of unleashing capital markets
towards steering the agenda and having
companies acting to really uh be
becoming more transparent around these
issues and that that's happening and
that's accelerating
so at the end of the day why those
sustainability factors do add value
to uh the share price now environmental
social governance performance they touch
upon very important levels of
performance within a firm
stakeholder relations we've seen the
power of undermining the brand value of
a firm and how the intangible value is
very linked to the perception of
customers and how quickly the brand
value could be deteriorated through an
environmental or social accident
aspects of cost liability reduction
typically a coefficiency is about
reducing or increasing Energy Efficiency
natural efficiency in other words
producing the same but with less waste
more recycling
cutting consumption of water and you
know producing that in the same quality
and what we see is that it's killing
costs when you have the price of energy
both gas
oil that high well guess what the energy
costs are very importable share of
operating costs in the large impact
sectors
but also on the whole image side human
capital was very important when you are
looking for a job I mean would you feel
interested in in uh working in an
industry from the past that is still
fossil that is entrenched in this world
all way of thinking that keeps polluting
and saying that's the best way to to
give a return to shareholders I guess
not you may want to work for a more
Progressive firm where they will try to
embrace the challenges of the future
innovate and try to change their image
and try to steer their their business
model towards a more sustainable
Direction
market share growth we've seen we've
seen those aspects
with interacting helping companies to
grow their market share we've seen that
with Toyota which I talked about
Innovation capacity well typically those
sustainability drivers are very complex
factors to manage and they are putting
constraint on companies and so they need
more r d so there are two ways for
companies to
to address sustainability challenges
either they put lawyers on the case
that's what GM did to by suing the state
of California to prevent them from
keeping their regulations on specifying
a certain percentage of electric cars
versus putting the engineers to the
cloud to devise new technologies well
they could do but they chose the other
route
so that's the kind of elements we look
at elements of time to Market prediction
so all these factors are very mainstream
they are really part of your
business management textbook and and by
looking at those factors in a systematic
manner sector by sector it allows us to
really capture differential of risk
exposure and quality of management and
and positioning towards uh strategic
profit opportunities
back to the climate change issue in some
Industries like the uh the electric
utility industry in the US only what you
find is that
the level of risk exposure to climate
change vary from 1 to 20 by a factor of
1 to 25 so the most exposed firm are 25
times more exposed to the others so of
course you can build scenarios on what
would be the price of of a ton of CO2 in
the future that's the kind of scenario
analysis that we do that allow us to
determine what is the uh the share price
exposure to those carbon risk
and overall what we're trying to to
measure is the materiality of those
social and environmental issues and what
what we've observed is that those
factors if they analyze the proper way
it's not simply just digging facts
putting them having you know throwing
the balls in the air and expecting that
you'll improve the return it's about
analysis so you can have a whole range
of
indicators or raw data that that you
take out but the difficulty is really
understand and analyze how these could
affect
the share price at the end how matter
all these issues would be and that's
what we're trying to do and that's what
um
many more analysts are trying to do
we've seen a whole range a whole
initiative actually I'll go mentioned
that the enhance analytics initiative
studied in Europe
what it is it is initiative to a niche
analytical power from the sell side
analyst all these investment Banks CT
UBS remember Lynch
and many others
who typically produce sell side research
on financial aspects to also look into
those sustainability issues and how they
could really um impact the financial
performance and so what the uh the AEI
does is that it's a
it's a pool of money that's actually
five percent of all their transactions
that that are being directed to those
Brokers that are providing the best SRI
research so in the last two years
um with the help of the unep community
Nation environmental program Financial
initiative there's been a whole pool of
of thinking to try to to ask the big
question with the mainstream how those
sustainability factors could be relevant
to share price performance how material
they could be and so you can if you dig
a bit if you go to a unified website you
will find a lot of those studies and
that's fairly enlightening not that they
are having the full picture
sometimes we're professional of
analyzing sustainability but these guys
are professional at analyzing financial
performance so the beauty of the
exercise is that they are really
capturing those factors and bringing
that to the mainstream and then so when
you see those uh reports on Goldman
Sachs or City Maryland UBS floating
around you have certainly big names
those guys have more than
you know 200 400 500 billion dollars in
the management a huge institutional
money
and then they start raising those
questions so then they start getting
interesting because the name is uh
you know sustainability factors become
mainstream
and so to the point that you know I
would argue that the uh the Paradox of
Sri
is that at the end of the day at the end
of the day
you know will be better off when there's
no longer need for Sri
because the whole money on the
management will be managed
with those factors of governance
environmental and social parameters that
make uh you know that that will be part
of the corporate makeup and the
financial analysis
of all those money managers so that we
can steer the the investment towards
those companies that are doing a better
job at limiting their risks
so does that work we heard the the
question before whether or not it is
true that we can add value by looking at
those sustainability factors
now again one of the difficulty we have
is that we're typically looking at
factors that are long-term well
long-term Horizon whereby Financial
entities have a short term so the
difficulty is to really materialize this
and to to Really zoom in the lens and
find the right time perspective
but overall in the last uh 10 years
you out of 70 separate studies from
Academia trying to look into the
correlation between environmental social
performance and financial performance
there's about 50 studies that show that
there's a positive correlation 10
studies show there's no correlation
no
and tensely I say it's neutral about
seven eight let's say it has no
correlation
recently the moscowitz price that is an
annual prize that is discerned by
awarded by the University of Haas
Berkeley with Lloyd Kurtz to reward the
best study has been awarded to some
students from Erasmus University yeah
her name is Nadia gunster and she
actually used Universe data on a
coefficiency to try to look at the uh
the link between environmental
performance and financial performance
and what she found is very profound over
the last seven or eight years of data
that we provided she found that overall
we added value
and it mostly added value by way of
avoiding those companies that that are
lower than average environmental
performance
so I mean this is the kind of of uh data
substantial that will
you know find its way on the table of
money managers and obviously try to
change
their way of thinking
so back to the various styles of how we
can apply those sustainability
strategies to a whole range of asset
classes as you know Pension funds they
do tactical allocations so they have
money in fixed income inequities in
small cap they Diversified regionally
and some even have money into cash or
even hedge funds so actually the good
news is that you can apply a
sustainability overlay to any style of
investing so starting from fixed income
and extreme fixed income when if you
write an equity you can also apply your
rating to a bond even though the damage
Dynamics is a bit different
uh you can have active strategies stock
picking let's do a strategy that I'll go
presented for Generation
Um a very narrow portfolio they had 35
stocks so you can be active with a quite
sizable tracking error to more
um with less Risk by taking an enhanced
index so what what it is you take an
index say S P 500 and you are tilting it
so you take moreover
of a bet on those stocks that have
rating above Triple B for minivest and
then you are underweighting those who
have a rating below Triple B so it's not
a Pew play sustainable sustainable fan
of sustainable companies it is using
this extra Financial research to add
Alpha to to add perspective to
investment strategy and making the
performance of your friend more robust
on the long term
but you can you can even go further
private Equity that's a very very
interesting area there's a number of
panel sessions that took place here on
cleantech and that's growing and it's a
very good thing because it's really
unleashing Capital markets to to invest
and and grow those uh those technologies
that have a huge potential and you even
have H fans alternative
absolute returns firms were trying to be
more socially responsible I mean that's
questionable whether or not it is a bit
up to you to determine that but it's um
some have applied our research to make a
long short
hedge fund so longing the triple n
shorting the Triple C from invest
other interesting elements for you to
grasp whether or not we can add value
whenever we analyze the sector
because it's really selected by sector
we don't analyze the bank with a
chemical company with another company
so here you take textile and apparel
we are charting the performance of the
stocks that are rated above average
versus the one that are that have a
below average sustainability rating with
us and what you see the differential in
yellow that's the share price
differential of those two portfolios now
in textile and apparel you have a 20 we
found a 23 out performance of a
three-year period
food and direct retail 25 of performance
two years food and food Product Industry
32 percent European Electric utilities
33 percent
you know with a certain amount of
volatility no it's not perfect but you
can see that there's raw materials to
apply to very well with control
phone management strategy
we've done other tests on various
investing styles with the U.S money
managers it was for a large US pension
fund U.S large cap grow through its
large cap value International large cap
so on and so forth I will skip the
details it's about you know looking at
the effect of giving you know taking the
risk using our research versus what
would be the the return of investing and
what you show is that every time each
bar is like you had more of the signal
from our ratings every time these
strategies are are beating the Benchmark
so that's that's very good news and what
we of course want to see is that those
Trends will hold over the years
and some of the fans that are using our
research Green Planet fund that's
managed by uh
French money Managers from
quite a large institutional player so
that's the Green Planet fund that is
using directly coefficiency analysis our
core value Research into a fund that's
showing with a very small
risk taking showing that it's beating
its index the msci world others
Spanish one here and we could go on and
but those funds exist and what they need
is is people like you to create the
demand whenever you have your money
invested you know ask what are you going
to do with these fans I mean not to rule
out those negative screenings I think
they have they have their place their
role to play they're doing good things
some money managers will tell you they
they will be hurting performance and
they may
but look for sustainability investing
way of looking at this broad scope of
governance and mental social issues to
drive the behavior of corporate
performance and practices
so I think